- Your name is so unique, it's Madelaine.
- Madelaine, yeah.
- Madelaine!
Oh, really!
- But my parents are hippies, and my--
- [Kelly] Love it!
- Very hippies, we would
eat from the garden,
my parents are vegans,
very crazy little kookies.
But my dad wanted to name me Street.
- Street!
- Which,
if we can just imagine for a second,
a poor little six-year-old
in elementary school,
like, "Gonna go walk
down the 'Street' today,"
people would make so many jokes about it.
- Yeah, well, I named my kid River.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
- Whoops!
- So I don't know that
that's any better.
- So, my mom was like,
"No, we have to do Lane,"
like, lane on the road, Madelaine, street.
So that was like a compromise, you know?
- I love your name, though,
I think it separates you out!
I think Madeline, Madeline
is beautiful enough,
but Madelaine is, it's gorgeous!
- Thank you so much!
So is Kelly!
- Well done, hippies!
- And Rob, look at that.
- Well done, possibly a lot of pot!
(audience applauds)
(Madelaine laughing)
Yeah. Yeah.
Well done!
So, you had a lot of odd jobs, here in LA.
I did as well, when I moved
here after high school, so--
- You did?
I'm fascinated.
- Yes.
What were yours?
- I want to ask you,
but okay, you can ask me first.
Six years ago, I would go
knock on people's doors,
and try to sell them new windows.
- Oh! Yeah.
- But I did it for two hours.
- Why wouldn't you knock on their windows?
- Why? (laughing)
(audience laughs)
- Should I break the window?
- [Kelly] Because that seems creepy.
- I should have broken the
window and then be like,
"Looks like you need a new window!"
(audience laughs)
(Kelly claps)
I woulda made some money then.
- That's amazing!
- Yeah, that was a weird job.
- I was a projectionist
at the Malibu Cinema,
when I was 13.
- Oh my God, my first job
was a movie theater!
- What?
Wait, when you were 13 years old?
- Yeah, it was truly child labor.
- Yeah, honestly!
- Like, violations.
(audience laughs)
But I put the reels on
in the wrong order.
- [Kelly] Oh, we--
(Madelaine laughs)
- Like, my job was to
literally thread the projector.
- But man, you screw that up,
you definitely ruin the film.
- It was over, yep.
- [Kelly] Like, "You know,
Bruce Willis dies."
- That was the end
of my career as a projectionist.
- [Kelly] In 'The Sixth Sense.'"
- So I was like, "You know what?
"Maybe I'll just be in movies."
- That's how you decided?
- It was a better trade, I feel.
(audience applauds)
- Yes!